now I'm guessing that many of you are  struggling to get your motion design to  look good because I hear it all the time  I hear things like I understand how to  make things move but I don't understand  why things on the screen don't look so  good the term motion designer is  actually a two-part term this means that  it's important to not only understand  the motion side of things but also the  design side of things if you want to be  considered a great motion designer you  need to understand both of these  learning the design side means that you  understand what it takes to make motion  design look good and when you know the  design side it opens up a whole new  world of possibilities for you learning  design can open up your career animation  is not the only possibility